tell me more about what you guys are
doing in el salvador at bitcoin beach to
help people actually get homes
yeah so i'm incredibly excited about
this um so we are working in hosante um
with uh with bitcoin beach and their
team um mike peterson and their team are
incredible and uh what we are doing is
we are designing a community of about
300 homes right in right in el zonte um
in el salvador and uh families will be
making their longer longer term monthly
mortgage payments um using bitcoin on
the lightning network through a local
wallet in bitcoin beach
and uh we've been very fortunate to
partner with with coinbase and coinbase
given giving so they funded the the
majority of this project and it's like
getting underway right now so we are um
building the homes right now and uh and
then families are being trained on how
to make their monthly payments um
through the wallet and uh using bitcoin
and lightning network and you know what
what we saw in this and the opportunity
is
these are families they're pretty much
all unbanked right and
a lot of them are getting their
remittances sent to them and
in order to make any type of payments um
in elsewhere they use the dollar so
they're paying in cash and dollars
they usually have to to travel somewhere
that's pretty far that disrupts their
day whether they're going to western
union or whether they're going to some
type of of lender or bank and they're
they're trying to pay in cash and then
whoever is collecting that
it's it's like the most it's the least
transparent way to track that over time
right over a longer period of time right
5 10 15 years where these families are
trying to
gain credit history they're trying to
make payments in the same way that
probably everybody listening where we
could just go on our phone and make a
payment and it doesn't have to disrupt
our whole day um and uh and right now
there's
it's really hard to do that if you're
unbanked you know and so um what we're
doing with uh and also and with um
coinbase giving and and this um this
pilot is proving that low-income
families can make consistent monthly
payments um in bitcoin on the lightning
network and being able to track that in
the most transparent way um being able
to have significant there's basically no
there's no fees there's no servicing
costs
because it's really just our team
sending an invoice to their phone as
opposed to the traditional way which
would be
human labor either coming to their door
or them having to go somewhere every
single month and make a payment like
it's it's a disaster to do over a long
period of time and so that's what's so
exciting um to us about about um using
the lightning network and enabling
families to
pay directly from their phone having
super transparent record of those
payments and um we can just do it all
digitally yeah what's the response been
so far from people in the community
so far amazing i mean families
before they opted in to be part of this
specific community um they knew that
this was going to be the payment method
we you know are doing we're doing
training right we're doing financial
literacy training we're doing um bitcoin
beach team has done an amazing job of um
of training people there of of how to
use the wallets and how to pay and uh
you know it's been incredible to see
especially the youth um really
understand and be excited about this
because they can see i mean they
obviously are all on their their phones
a lot just like we are and um and
they're like why would we not just pay
from our phones instead of having to try
to do everything in cash basically right
so